Senegal's opposition leader and
presidential hopeful has been charged
with plotting and Insurrection and other
offenses the state prosecutor says Usman
Sanko will remain in custody after being
detained on Friday the new charges come
weeks after he was sentenced to two
years in prison on separate allegations
of corrupting the youth that ruling
sparked Nationwide protests sonko says
the case against him was politically
motivated
he will be prosecuted for calling for
Insurrection criminal conspiracy
undermining State security plotting
against State Authority acts and
Maneuvers intended to compromise public
security and create serious political
unrest criminal conspiracy and
connection with the terrorist Enterprise
as well as theft
kahi tells us more about the charges
sonko is about to face
they include conspiracy against the
state calling for Insurrection
association with people who are
associated with so-called Terror
organizations and undermining State
security his supporters say this is just
the latest episode in years of
intimidation just to give you some
background here in 2021 he was arrested
and charged with rape
in June of this year those charges were
dropped and he was found guilty of what
was described as Corruption of the youth
that sentence means in theory legally
that he is not allowed to stand in next
year's elections
the situation began to defuse he was
serving effectively his two-year term at
his house and it's understood that's
because the authorities here say had he
have gone to jail the situation would
have got too out of control it was seen
as being too inflammatory among his
supporters bear in mind that over the
last two years over 40 people have been
killed in demonstrations so the
situation here in the Senegalese capital
is calm for now there have been calls
for protests his party says the future
of President sonko their future
president rests with us the Senegalese
people Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
Dakar